ve
salı tarihi
maçları sırasında ateşin bulunmasıyla
başladı
bu
insanların ateşi bulduktan sonra ki
şeytan sonra
pişirdiler
odalarda katmış olduk fazla
Kızlar
aslında biz bugün burada orta ihtiyaç
ağları bir gelecek istiyoruz Çünkü
insanlar
çalışmalardan
etrafında toplanıp
[Müzik]
paylaştıkları bir nokta oluşturur
Selam bugün baktığınızda asla bizlere o
ateşin etrafında toplanmış ve o gün
gittiğimizde paylaşan İnsanlık
yaz gidip sonbahar geldiğinde o tarla
ardıcı tohumlar
ilkbaharda açan o çiçeklerin tohumları o
kuvveti rüzgarlarla çok uzak topraklara
saldır giderler
bu
Anadolu bozkırında doğru
bozkırı vardı kıza şöyle bir toprak
alsanız be o toprağa bakarsanız Bu
sadece kuru bir toprak dersiniz ama o
toprağın içerisinde hep acılar var de
kedicikler var ne ağaçlar var
aslında kopuk o kuvvetli rüzgarlarda o
toprakları ulaşmış
bunlardır
Aslında
öğretmenlik
olacak ve soğuk
Oturumları güvenli gösterdi
Şimdi
Anadolu
büyük
[Müzik]
gerçekten çok zor ya
ve Herşeyden bir haber bir şekilde
yaşıyorsun
ben seni de Sınıfta kaldım lise son
sınıfta bir matematik dersinde dersen
çok sıkıldı be of
anlamıyorum
hızla geldim ve
ve
sonrasında okul bitmek üzere neredeyse
bir ay var
Bir öğretmen İşte o sonra topraktaki
tohumu gösteren insanlar
Gülizar Kara
ben o dönemde çok resim çiziyorum Her
yer resim yaptım görmenin arkasına
buldum heryere bütün arkadaşlarımı
öğretmenlerimi bunu biliyordu ama o
koskoca 11 yıllık bir süreçte Şimdi bana
o Tohumdan bahsetmemiş Yani insan asla
bir oldu toprakta ve içerisinde Derici
her ne var ne ağaç vardı ama siz Eğer
bir otur bunları göster verseniz yoktu
güzel
bana dedi ki sen de çizim yeteneği
vardır yani
ben hiç fark etmediği bir şey birisi
bana göstermiştir yani o günden sonra
içinde bir toplum olduğunu fark etmeye
başlayın şimdi bir tohum vardı Ve bu
tohumu Yaşar etmeliydim okul bittikten
sonra otomobile etmek için elimden gelen
her şeyi yaptım çünkü şimdi bir tohum
olduğunu fark etmiştir Yani bir avuç
Anadolu bozukluğu bildim
sonrasında
boyunca sıkı bir şekilde çalışan o
bu olayın başkasıyla Polislik sınavına
girdim ve pozisyona girdiğimde bir kart
mevzu vardı yerlerini göster değil fark
o kartları gösterdi bana gösterdi
Derince üçlü setler Onu
gösterdim
w906 dediler Sonra
[Müzik]
hastalık varmış
çünkü benim
lazım
Sonra da artık
çünkü şey
bu
bittikten sonra aynı zamanda
üniversitedeyken de tiyatro ile
ilgileniyor burada küçük bir sahne
koydum 60-70 kişilik bir sahne sonrası
Orada hem sahnenin uyuyordum ya da sen
benim elimde hem de
Oyunları'nda Gül bir yerde
bu Dört yılın sonunda
mecazi anlamda söylüyorum bir tane
başladı vardır mesela Doğduğumuzda
görmeye başladığınızda her şeyi geceler
Her şeyi bakarsınız çok anlamsız gelse
de bir kumanda ya bakarsınız inşa
bakarsınız her şeyi Hayret vericidir ya
da bir şehre gittiğinizde herşeyi Hayret
verirsin aslına bakarsanız binalara
bakarsınız her şey fotoğrafını çekmeye
çalışacağım Çünkü bir şehre gitmek ve
Bulunduğunuz yerden uzaklaşmak mıdır
Hatta başka bir yere gittiğimizde senin
rengini
adlı olduk gittiğinizde
yaşamaya başladığınızda Artık
kime ait olduğunu sesinden farkedersiniz
kaldı mı
o Çünkü hayatın hep burada iyileşmesinin
ülkeyi ve dünyayı tanıyın istedim
Her şeyi artık sadece
kalem vardı ve bir çanta var mı
[Müzik]
bu 35 liraya nereye gidiyorsa o an oraya
bilet alma Laser ediliyordu o an hemen
malzemelerimizi sağlığım yola çıktım
giderken Valizin para kazandım şoförü
çizimi para kazandım onları ziyaret
ettiğimizde katıldım ve çizmeye başladım
o
Bu
Şehir şehir dolaşıp sokaklarda bir
kaldırım taşına oturarak ortaya
çizebilirsiniz bunun için sadece şehri
ihtiyacınız yok küçücük köye gittiniz
bize bu bakabilirsiniz bir portre
çizilir Yani aslında bu kalem Sizin için
çok değerli bir hazine yani dizisini
çizerek aldığınız parayla o gün yemek
yiyebilirsiniz o gün Bir otelde
kalabilirsiniz yoktunuz için bir bilet
alabilirsiniz O yüzden sahip olduğum her
şeye gerçeklerini kalemle sahip olduğumu
söyleyip kesinlikle doğrudur
ardından sadece bunu yapmak istemedim
teyzem istedim büyük tanımak için
ülkenin sokaklarını gitmeniz lazım
insanda dokunmanız lazım ürünlerin
denmez lazım
ama ben
küçücük bir kasabada doğum günü ve ve
oturumların farkına varmadığımız için
bir gibi aynı koşulları o çocukları
ulaşmak istedim köy okullarını köy
okullarında çocuklarla
şimdiki tulumlu ortaya çıkarmaları için
onu alır resim yaptım okullarda duvar
resimleri yaptım gönüllü olarak
gittiğinde 200'ün Sen de okula duvar
resimleri yaptım
ve ardından dünyayı geleceğini düşündüm
ve kuzey günlerden başlayarak Japonya
hayvana doğru bir yolculuğa çıktım
bu yolculukta da aynı zamanda Ben
Türkiye'de değiştiriyordum dediğim
ülkelerde Türkiye'den Birliği rahatsız
etmeyin yani kültürümüzü oraya
gittiğinden hem okullara duvar resim
yapıyordun Hem bizi anlatırdım hem de o
ülkelerin çizgi film kültür ve sanatını
araştırıyorum Biraz alayım şey saat
çalışması yaptığım için bunu araştırmak
ses çalışmak için çok faydalı bir şey
Japonya İlkinde ve çizimden Araştırma
yaptığımda bir şey fark ettim bizim
dünya çizgi film kültür ve sanatın da
yalnızca iki satırlık bir yer
kapladığımız farketmez ilk olarak çok
üzücü bir şey
ardından Neden bizim de dünyaya mal
olmuş
Evrensel
değerler Taşıyan çizgi film Yok yok
değişim
bu sonra
tekrar Türkiye
bu
sol tarafta 5 lira göreceksin
ilk önce bir çizgi film Okulu kurmak
istedim yani çizgi filmleri şiddeti
Propaganda gibi
satmak için içerisine konulan
o küçük ayrıntıları gördüm gerçekten de
çizgi filmlerin yüzlerini bir kenara
atarsın çizgi film üretmek istiyorum
sizi kim yapmak istediğiniz bana destek
olmak istiyorum ve bunu meslek edinmek
istediği insanlara imkan sağlamak
istiyorum Türkiye'nin adında günler sizi
halinde oldukça yerlere taşımak
istiyorum dedim
gelince 5 lira vardı ve Kalenin vardı bu
varsa gerçekten hiç korkmanıza gerek yok
kaşığı gittim haberi öncesinde de çok
hayvan ve belediye mesaj at O Evet açtım
ana diğer konuşabileceğim yaptım
kimse dönüş yapmadı takip döneminin kaç
ayakkabı bizden bayağı
o 16 biroğlu Hasret edeceğini söyledi
kullanılmayan ahır olarak kullanılan bir
okul öğrenciler taşımalı verilmiş okul
boşalmış dedik sana buraya vereceğim
burayı kullanabilirsin
Elektrik yok Su yok gelince para yok o 5
lirayla
gittim poğaça yaptım bir çadır aldım
biraz erzak aldım
bu Kazmayı aldım ve okula git
o altı doğru onarmak için bir ay boyunca
orada gerçekten de zor şartlarda
çalışıyor
çünkü köylü bir kişi gelmiş oraya çok
anlamsız geliyor O
ne zaman okunuyor bir çizgi film okuma
olsun
kim destek olmadığını da orada üzülerek
Çünkü anlamadıkları bir projeye destek
olmaz Sizi tanıyorlar Allahımız gerek
göstermeniz diye
Tabii Avcıları zaman bir okul olduğu
için yılanlar Okulu iddia etmişler bir
sabah uyandığında olduğunda yılan var
Yani bütün bunları görmek için zor bütün
çok alıştım gibi masmavi divanları
uyarmaya
çoğu zaman artık bir şekilde orada
çalışıyorsunuz okulun almaya
çalışıyorsunuz tek başınız bir acımızdan
tutan herhangi bir iz yok Bir süre sonra
projenin sosyal medyadan anlattığımda
insanlar projeyi de uygular Türkiye'nin
ilk çizgi film bağımsız bir çizgi olacak
ve sonra
ama inşallah Kimisi kum aldık ise
çimento aldığı gezerdi biz bu okula
katkı vermiş bir yıl içerisinde
binin üzerinde öğrencinin bize
sizinleyim aldığı bir okula düşündü o
insanların malzeme listesini
bulunmasıyla gelip gönüllülük yapmasıyla
içerisinde
bir çizgi film atölyesi kütüphanesini
uzak şehirden gelen öğrencilerin
kalabileceği
yazıhanesi olan bir çizgi film okula
dönüştü
amacımız suyu çocuklar tablet ve telefon
kullanılan hamuru sadece bir tüketim
malzemesi olarak kullanılan
ihtiyacımız ama aynı zamanda üretime
dahil olmakta ihtiyacım var
bu
Kaymakamlık ya da herhangi bir şekilde
öğretmenler bizim ulaşırlar biri var 15
öğrenci bir öğretmen kim kalarak orada
çizgi filmi izle alabiliyorlar ya da
gibi Birlik olarak derece okulları
geldim oradan çizim eğitimi
alabiliyorlar bu yıl da binlerce
öğrencinin oraya gidip o eğitimi alması
bizim ülkemizi çizgi film kültür ve
sanatına katkısı olacak değil mi aynı
zamanda onların çizgi film izlerken
şiddetten uzak propagandadan uzanan
gerçekten dediği doğru güzelliği anlatan
çizgi filmleri izlemeleri dolara aynı
zamanda öğretmiş olmuş
baktığınızda şunu diyebilirsiniz bu
Toprak
bu biri Pro Toprak tane iş var yani Bir
kelebeğin
bir şey yerler çiçeklerin olduğu
yerlerde Biz istiyoruz ki gelebilirim
ama her görmek istiyorsak da şey
yaptık bakalım